as we all know apple's september event
is happening this tuesday and even
though john prosser already leaked the
design of the iphone 14 we're still all
excited for the iphone 13 because it'll
be packing some long-awaited features
like a 120hz display panel a smaller
notch portrait mode video recording
potentially and always on display and of
course the new a15 bionic chip and
luckily we've recently been getting some
huge leak bombs in terms of the a15
chips performance and how it compares to
the current a14 chip and the next-gen
chips over on the android side like the
unreleased equinox 2200 from samsung and
the snapdragon 898 from qualcomm so for
this video i did a bunch of leak
research and number crunching to come up
with the performance numbers for each of
those three flagship chips so that you
guys will know exactly what to expect
from the iphone 13 as well as the best
android phones on the market next year
now before i get into which chip will be
going into which flagship device i want
to first show off our new apple product
icon shirt which you can find down in
the merge shelf below this video if you
want to help support this channel
according to a new leak out of taiwan on
kleon.net the new equinox 2200 chip will
be used in the european and south
american galaxy s22 ultra models when
it's announced next year as samsung's
unpacked event and as for the new
qualcomm snapdragon 898 that chip will
be going into the north american
southeast asian and indian galaxy s22
ultra models and of course the a15 will
be going into every single iphone 13
model out there even the lower end ones
so to start off with the leaks let's
jump right into the leaked graphics
performance of the a15 bionic champ
according to that leaker on clean.net
the a15 sample from july was able to
score
198 fps in the gfx bench manhattan 3.1
benchmark and just to give you some
context on just how good that is i ran
that same test on my iphone 12 pro max
and it scored 140 fps so what this
basically means is that the a15 chip's
gpu is around 41 faster than the one in
the a14 and that's because apple is
adding an extra gpu core to make it a 5
core gpu compared to the a14s 4 core
however the biggest issue with the
leaked performance of the a15 is that it
suffers from severe thermal throttling
the leaker claims that after the third
and following manhattan benchmark runs
they scored a much lower 140 to 150 fps
because of overheating or thermal
throttling that basically means that
we're seeing around 24 to 29 thermal
throttling off the top of the maximum
score so what i did is i ran the same
test three times back to back on my
iphone 12 max to test the throttling and
here are the results that i came up with
the a14 chip throttles down to around
119 fps from the peak score of 140
compared to the a15 chip throttling down
to 140 to 150 from 198. so the good news
here is that even under maximum
throttling the a15 is still faster than
the peak score of the a14 with that said
i also ran the same benchmark test on
our galaxy s21 ultra and we got a peak
score of 116 fps with a very minimal dip
to 108 on the third back-to-back run
which shows that it barely has any
throttling at all compared to both of
the iphone chips however the a14 chip is
still faster while throttling and the
a15 obviously blows it away and now with
that said let's finally start looking at
the leaked benchmark scores from the
equinox 2200 and the snapdragon 898
according to tron on twitter it was able
to score between a maximum of 170.7
and
181.8 fps in the manhattan 3.1 test so
it basically beats out the a14 chip but
it's still well behind the a15 and as
far as the throttling he claimed that it
scored 127.5 fps after the third run so
that points to around 25 to 30 percent
thermal throttling which is very similar
to how much the a15 chip throttles and
the leaker on clean.net also confirmed
that the equinox 2200 suffers from
severe throttling due to the tdp limit
now moving on to the new snapdragon 898
chip the leaked peak performance in
manhattan 3.1 is
158.4 fps which is quite a bit lower
than the other two chips which is
definitely disappointing for all of us
here in the united states because this
is the chip that's going into the us
version of the galaxy s22 ultra now
unfortunately we don't have the third
run data for the snapdragon 898 but the
leaker on clan.net did mention that it
has less throttling compared to the a15
and the equinox 2200 so i'm gonna give
it the benefit of the doubt and put the
throttling at around 15 to 20 percent
instead of 25 to 30 on the other two
chips and if we calculate it that way it
puts the third run performance at around
127 to 135 fps which is lower than both
the a15 and the equinox and that has
been confirmed to be the case by another
leaker named the galax on twitter
showing that the snapdragon is the
slowest chance so with all that said we
can see that the a15 ship is still in
the top spot in terms of peak graphics
performance as well as the throttle down
performance but i'm pleasantly surprised
that the android side is starting to
catch up which is good news for
everybody now with the graphics side out
of the way let's go ahead and look at
the cpu performance psi according to a
hong kong media company that i can't
pronounce the a15 chip is going to be
built on tsmc's improved 5 nanometer
technology but the big change is that
the a15 is expected to be based on arm's
brand new arm v9 architecture so it's
going to support sve2 extension
technology and it's going to have other
benefits but as far as the performance
they're expecting a 20
improvement on the cpu side so if we add
20 to the single core performance that
we got with the a14 chip the a15 should
score around
1900 points which is very impressive
because it's faster than the current m1
chip and if we apply that same 20
improvement to the multi-core side as
well we're left with over 5 000
multi-core points which is absolutely
insane for an iphone now as for the
android chips it's a bit more tough to
track down the performance gains for the
cpu but we did find some new leaks
according to the user digital chat
station on weibo the snapdragon 898
should also provide a 20 performance
boost over the current 888 but at the
expense of increased temperatures now
since he's talking about high thermals
we can assume he's talking about the
multi-core performance which we're gonna
save for a little bit later now
calculating the single core performance
should be very easy because the layout
of the 898 chip has already been leaked
and the main performance core will be
using qualcomm's new x2 prime core along
with a bunch of lower powered cores
according to arm themselves this x2 core
is 16 faster than the previous x1 core
so if we go by that calculation the
snapdragon 898 should get a single core
score of around 1308
compared to 1128 on the snapdragon 888
now as far as the equinox 2200
apparently it could be coming with the
exact same x2 core which would basically
give it identical single core
performance to the snapdragon and if
this is true apple's a15 is gonna
absolutely obliterate both of them in
the single core department being over 46
faster and as far as the multi-core side
for the equinox a leak from my drivers
claims that it's going to be using a
similar layout to the chipset on the
snapdragon 898 so it should also have a
similar multi-core performance number
and as we can see the a15 chip continues
to blow them both out of the water so
with all that said it's pretty obvious
that apple's a15 will continue to
dominate the competition even though
it's going to be releasing next week
compared to those chips coming out
months later so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and learned something
new and if you did go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out our merch down below thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]